0 degré à quasiment neuf heures du matin
la température provoque quelques
réticences dans ce groupe de jeunes
canard mais l'éleveur ne leur laisse pas
le choix
la vie au grand air est un élément
prépondérant dans cette ferme solognote
keller c'est un oiseau migrateur
donc il habitué à avigdor le fait d'être
élevés en plein air ça ça évite tout
développement de virus de bactéries
l'état sanitaire des volatiles et ici la
priorité absolue en 2016 la crise
aviaire a fait chuter de 30% la
production de foie gras du sud ouest
cette catastrophe a incité l'éleveur
solognot à investir dans des dispositifs
de prévention une otan cro sont clôturés
avec des grillages qui sont enterrées et
il ya des files de clôture électrique de
manière qu'on ait aucun nuisibles qui
rentre dans l'est dans les parcours qui
peut amener qui pourra amener un virus
ou une maladie les précautions
sanitaires ont porté leurs fruits
les canards de la fauconnière un
croisement de canard de barbarie pour la
production de chair et de canards de
pékin pour leur capacité à développer un
foie gras de 5 à 600 grammes ont gagné
la confiance d'une large clientèle
régionale aux canards sont gavés avec du
maïs grain entier précuits donc on a on
a des foies gras qui se conservent mieux
et qui sont plus faciles à travailler
soit en bocaux soit entérinée la
réussite est totale
la fourmilière fait vivre une dizaine de
salariés et commercialise 38 beaucoup
par an la moitié de la production est
écoulée en forme directe à la ferme